Given two normalized vectors, the cosine of the angle between them is computed
by the dot product operation. So this is the dot, it's a big dot, and these are
denoted as vectors by putting arrows over them. The dot product is equivalent to
multiplying the x value of A times the x value of B and so on with y and z and
then adding these up together. Say I have these two normalized vectors, and I
want to find the cosine of the angle between them. The dot product is then 0
times 0.8 and so on, next to values multiplied and so on. This comes out to be
these three terms added together, which equals 0.6. So this is the cosine of the
angle between these two vectors. Out of curiousity, if we take the Arc cosine of
this value, 0.6, we get 53.13 degrees. However, we don't really care about the
angle, we truly want the cosine. As this is how much we'll scale the light's
contrubution to the surface. The dot product is a little mysterious, and is so
fundamental to a large part of computer graphics, that it's worth buliding up
some understanding of what it really means. Why does this operation have any
connection with cosine?